alright there is bipartisan agreement
among senators though on one point
tonight calling on China to immediately
close all those wet markets let's bring
a GOP senator from Utah Mike Lee to talk
about that much more senator good to
have you back with us thank you it's
good to be with you okay so let's start
with China you know we have from the
national interest talking about the fact
that America and China are still gonna
have to get along when this is over
saying the crisis will eventually pass
but there will be others and they too
will require Washington and Beijing to
subordinate strategic competition to
humidities requirements the pandemic has
placed that imperative unto the sharpest
possible relief senator will they do it
should we do it but look I think no
matter what they're going to be dire
consequences for China admits this is a
place that fostered the development of
the virus to begin with and concealed
its severity and I think regardless of
any action government takes consumers
themselves are gonna take action I
expect government will take action as
well and we're gonna see trade
restricted for a ton and China is going
to be a net loser in that okay let's
talk about the fact that over on the
hill today we thought the Senate might
take some action it didn't get done the
Secretary of Treasury minuchin has been
talking with congressional leaders
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell had
talked about the fact that they were
trying to get something done by sort of
a voice vote unanimous consent that
could move this new funding along to
replenish those coffers for small
business loans it didn't happen because
Democrats came forward with their own
lists of what they wanted to add to that
here's what the House speaker had to say
today you may have seen this morning
that this stunt was performed by the
and it leader knowing that it would fail
many people who do not have banking
relationships were going to be last in
line and that's why when they ask for
more money we said well let's help
everybody here let's help the bank do
what their their said to do she's not
the only one calling out
leader McConnell the top Democrat in the
Senate Chuck Schumer said this in a
tweet senator Mitch McConnell just
blocked a bill that provides money for
small businesses hospitals testing and
more instead of working with the House
and Senate Democrats he pulled a
political stunt they both use that same
word stun senator what happened on the
floor today well first of all it's very
clear that there's Democratic pollution
on what the message should be what
happened on the floor the Senate today
was disgraceful the fact that Democrats
came forward and refused to lend
additional support for a program that
just days ago Shannon they supported
wholeheartedly and they refused to
support it today knowing that millions
of Americans are in need of this
assistance simply because they wanted to
score additional points they wanted to
build government in the way they deem
fit this isn't right and they know it
well there are worries across the aisle
about the price tags that we're talking
about now getting into five six trillion
dollars in relief in some cases
Mya McGinnis who is the president of
committee for a responsible federal
budget said this it feels like every day
now politicians are trying to use this
national emergency to enact their
favorite policies while avoiding paying
for them now we all agree that this is a
dire moment in our nation's economy but
how do we get a handle on what we are
doling out of taxpayers dollars and how
we eventually handle the deffend debt
and deficit that's being generated by
the relief packages that so many people
are counting on right now looks at
there's no question that we've got a
debt and deficit problem we do have to
work our way out of this situation that
we find ourselves in with the global
pandemic but the Democrats solution to
this was to add even more to the price
tag and to cause this money to go even
less far that was wrong okay won't ask
you to because you were tracking
something involving hospital beds they
are very valuable right now everybody
keeping an eye making sure that these
are available in the various communities
especially
those were they're having spikes but
there's now some kind of trade dispute
or something going on regarding actual
mattresses that are used for hospital
beds what can you tell us there is
indeed look there's a company called
Leggett & Platt good company they make
good mattresses but they've done a very
bad thing here they've filed the
petition with the international trade
commission the net effect of which is to
shut down the importation of mattresses
at a time when we've got fifty to
seventy thousand mattresses that are
needed in hospital rooms right now the
domestic manufacturers led by Leggett &
Platt cannot manufacture any being close
to that in the next five months so it
look they've made a mistake they need to
admit they were wrong III
everybody said intended to a mulligan
now and then but they need one here and
they made a big mistake and I think it's
a mistake for them to be utilizing the
ITC process to shut out competition in a
way that's gonna harm the American
people during a global pandemic limiting
their and access the hospital beds which
are an essential medical device needed
for copic 19 treatment yeah there's so
many things that come along with this
pandemic that we couldn't have foreseen
even 6-8 weeks ago so it gets
complicated
all right senator we're glad you are
looking well after your own brush with a
quarantine and we hope to see the Senate
get something together as quickly as
possible for these small businesses
thank you for your time thank you sooner